à washington rien n'a filtré des
discussions ce soir entre barack obama
et le roi de jordanie qui a promis plus
tôt de répliquer avec force à la mort
d'un otage jordan hier en séries ce
matin le groupe armé état islamique a
mis en ligne une vidéo dans laquelle un
jeune pilote capturé en décembre et
brûlé vif au milieu des décombres d'une
frappe de la coalition
je joins notre correspondante marie-eve
bédard à beyrouth
marielle faut dire que le groupe a
repoussé si c'est possible
les limites de la barbarie encore une
fois où est difficile d'imaginer mais
avec ces images d'un homme qui serait le
pilote jordan est mazel casas b brûlé
vif à l'intérieur d'une cage
ce sont vraiment des images
insoutenables et dans cette vidéo qui
est assez long quand même qui dure 22
minutes
le groupe armé état islamique joue
beaucoup sur la symbolique tout dans le
vidéo rappelle les bombardements de la
coalition dans l'imagerie on voit des
extraits d'une vidéo du pilote qui
s'adresse directement la caméra qui
parle des opérations qui sont menées par
la coalition contre les groupes armés
islamistes
entrecoupé d'image de jean calciné dans
les décombres des bombardements il
finalement cette scène où il est brûlé
vif à l'intérieur d'une cage se déroule
sur les lui-même d'un bombardement
présumé de la coalition aux alentours de
rac en syrie bon on sait que le groupe
etat islamique a déjà tué de nombreux
musulmans mais c'est quand même la
première fois qu'un musulman de
naissance et exécuter aussi publiquement
dans une vidéo qu'est ce que ça implique
non seulement c'est un musulman mais
c'est aussi le premier des otages du
groupe armé état islamique qui est un
membre actif de la coalition qui luttent
contre le groupe armé islamique
un pilote dans la vidéo d'ailleurs à la
toute fin on donne aussi le nom et
l'identité de plus d'une dizaine de
pilotes de l'armée de l'air de la
jordanie avec énormément de détails leur
adresse les informations sur leur combi
médias sociaux facebook twitter
on met leur tête à prix essentiellement
et on appelle les musulmans à s'en
prendre à ses pilotes
alors c'est dire qu'on cherche à mettre
beaucoup de pression sur ces pays
surtout peut-être les pays arabes qui
participe à la coalition du groupe de
lutte contre le groupe armé islamique
justement est-ce que ça risque de
remettre en question ont entendu le roi
abdallah aujourd'hui mais est-ce que ça
risque de remettre en question la
participation de la jordanie à cette
coalition
parce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui la colère
des gens dans les rues
dahmane une colère qui s'exprime et oui
son coup du choc mais qui n'est pas
nouvelle céline de plus en plus les
jordaniens critique ouvertement la
décision de leur gouvernement de
participer à cette coalition surtout
dans les ont
sud de la jordanie les zones tribales où
les gens se demandent pourquoi aller
combattre une guerre qui ne voient pas
comme étant la leur cela dit quand on
était en attente des nouvelles du
pilotes ses critiques se sont un peu
calmées par ce qu'on cherchait à obtenir
la collaboration du gouvernement pour
négocier la libération mais aujourd'hui
les gens sont en colère ils veulent ils
demandent une vengeance pour le meurtre
du pilote jordanien est ce que leur
colère va être canalisée par le
gouvernement qui promet maintenant
l'exécution d'une prisonnière irakienne
que le groupe hermitage islamique a
cherché à faire libérer contre la
libération du pilote jordanien on promet
maintenant de l'exécuter dans les heures
qui viennent avec quelques autres
condamnés à mort pour avoir participé à
des actes terroristes en jordanie où est
ce que cette colère là va se retourner
contre le gouvernement et sa
participation au sein de la coalition ça
reste à voir
oui beaucoup de questions encore merci
beaucoup marie-eve vous en paix